Is there a reason why XSS is like your shit?
Did you like, were you a JS developer before?
No, not at all.
I'm also a terrible developer in any way.
But what I like about this, actually, we touched upon it a bit.
I like code review, but also at the same time clicking buttons.
And I guess that's where JavaScript comes in, right?
All righty, we're synced up.
We're synced.
We're ready to go.
All right.
Here we are in Portugal.
We're in Joel's super swanky hotel room here.
So thanks for that one, man.
And we've got Rene here with us today.
And we are all here in Portugal participating in Integrity's live hacking event.
It's been a blast so far.
So we'll talk a little bit about that today.
But yeah, Rene, welcome to the podcast, man.
Thank you for having me.
Rene, Rene.
I always say Rene, but it's Rene.
Rene is fine, too.
Whatever you like.
You know, whatever, man.
Just Rene Pack or whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So essentially, you know, we kind of wanted to talk a little bit about Integrity this episode.
We'll cover the podcast, you know, on this podcast, the live hacking event that we're
participating in right now.
And I also want to get your experience, you know, your take on your experience with Integrity
as a top Integrity hacker there.
But first, why don't you give us a little bit of an intro to who you are as a hacker and
where you're full-time bug bounty right now, right?
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, so I'm Rene, Rene, better known as Rene Pack.
Right.
Nice.
39 years old.
So I'm old.
Not that old.
I live in the Netherlands with my wife and my daughter.
Yeah, recently, well, recently, one and a half years ago, I went full-time bug bounty hunter.
Nice.
And I have an interesting career path coming from studying to be a professional musician.
Yeah, yeah.
So you told us about this.
You were like, we were setting up the whole, you know, recording, mobile recording setup
and you were like, yeah, actually, you know, I studied like recording and audio engineering, right?
Yeah.
So why don't you tell us a little bit about that?
Because that's not exactly the most standard path to get into bug bounty.
No, so as a child, I joined the local orchestra.
Like we have a, like, I think you have them as well in America, like the college band type
of orchestra.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm a percussionist.
So I joined as a little kid and I enjoyed myself and I was good at playing percussion.
And then you finish high school, you have to think like, what's next?
What do I want to do?
And everyone's like, oh, you're such a good musician.
You should do something with it.
And then, yeah, you're young and you don't know what you do want to do with life.
So I picked that path.
Well, it's kind of interesting, man.
I feel like the bug bounty industry, it has an odd number of people that are not traditional
IT people that have joined the industry.
And I'm not sure if that's just because it's accessible or whether like the brain, you know,
the non-traditional brain or something like that really lends itself to hacking.
Yeah, I think it's a bit of both.
Yeah.
I think I can imagine that.
And Joel does a bunch of music stuff too.
So all you guys, all you big brain music guys.
Yeah.
I was going to say, I had a very similar, like I grew up, I was always playing music.
Like I got into music school and when it came time to be like, oh, what do I want to do?
Um, computers was basically, it was like drawing me in that direction.
And so I decided to go that route instead of going the music route.
But I think like that, that creative type of aspect where, you know, music I think has
been shown to like, you know, increase, you know, learning capabilities and all that kind
of stuff.
And it's really good for, you know, young children as they grow up and all that.
So I, I'm not at all surprised that there's so many like creative and that type of people
within the hacking space.
Yeah.
Well, then I'm screwed because, because I, no, I do, I do play piano and I sing, but like,
I, uh, you know, I guess my traditional music skills are not very like, essentially my, the
extent of my piano abilities is like, you know, I can do octaves on the left hand and then on
the right hand, I just like have the chord, you know, that I'm playing.
And then I just kind of, you know, wave my hand like this, you know, uh, and hope that
the, the melody comes out.
But normally if you can stay in, in your key, you know, it'll, it's not too bad.
Um, yeah.
So I guess normally, uh, with these, with these, uh, interviews, we like to go down the path
of like, uh, you know, give us a little career history, tell us how you ended up in
Buck Bounty.
But I think I'm going to, I think I'm going to take a, take a little side turn today.
I want to hear about some technical shit right off the bat.
Um, okay.
So you, you tweeted out a while back, big bounty that you got.
Tell, um, can you talk a little bit about in, in as, as much detail as you can talk about
that vulnerability, what kind of bone it was?
Tell us a little bit about that.
So it's actually, it's actually kind of funny though.
So the, the vulnerability that I found is actually my profile picture on Twitter.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
So it wasn't on Twitter, but
Grabs phone.
Starts looking at Twitter.
No, no.
I, I, I actually found the same vulnerability on multiple programs.
Uh, and technically it's, it's like a stored XSS.
Oh, this is an NFT.
In an NFT.
Right.
So some platforms allow you to create an NFT and they do, they have like systems like lazy
minting or stuff like that.
Sure.
Where you basically only submit it to their platform.
And once it's sold, they will create an actual NFT for you.
Ah.
But what you also can do obviously because the Ethereum blockchain is accessible to anyone.
Right.
I just, uh, like, uh, uh, how do you call it?
Uh, like minted my own NFTs.
Right.
Where I don't have to deal with a kind of all kinds of input validations, et cetera.
Sure.
And just used every kind of, uh, cross-site scripting payload in every kind of a metadata
field that I could find.
And, uh, a lot of these platforms like include everything that matches a certain standard to
their platform.
Is that the, what is that the ERC 712?
721.
Is that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Very cool, man.
I, I, I, I did a little stint.
I guess maybe, what was it?
Like, uh, it's probably 2020 or 2021, you know, during the COVID, the COVID dark times,
you know, into the, into the, um, web three hacking space.
And.
You know, I see there's a lot of potential there, but for me, it was not like my go-to
thing, but I've also seen people like you and, and, uh, some other names that I won't
call out directly that have really been able to milk the web three web two bridge.
That's exactly.
I've had exactly kind of the same path.
So I was interesting, obviously in this big bounties being paid out for web three issues.
So I went to, uh, down the path studying solidity and, uh, learning about smart contract vulnerabilities.
Yeah.
But I really disliked just doing code review.
Like I, I like, I actually really like code review when it's in a combination with like
clicking buttons or debugging stuff and see what happens next.
Yeah.
And just solely the code review of like solidly contracts is, was a bit challenging.
So that's why I went down the, the web three rep to like where they meet.
!!
Yeah.
I, I've done a little bit of web three research as well.
And it's such an interesting space because there's so many different web two technologies
that connect into it.
And, you know, basically in order to interface with most of the web three stuff, you have to
have some sort of web two interface, right?
Like open sea, for example, it is purely based on like web three.
It's, you know, readings information from the blockchain.
It's doing all these things that are based in web three, but it itself is a web two website.
Right.
And so I think that, that, that sort of gap in between is where there's a lot of room
for those types of vulnerabilities that you talk about, where if it adheres to this standard,
right?
Yeah.
And it's also, I'm really, yeah, it's like a blessing and the curse.
I'm really into XSS.
Yeah.
Especially in the web three, uh, eco sphere is like, it's much more critical actually,
even if you have an XSS, because there is no server side stuff, basically.
Yeah, absolutely.
And there's so much stuff that happens with like these browser based wallets.
Yeah, definitely.
And then, you know, MetaMask and all that kind of stuff.
So if you get an XSS in any of those contexts, there's so much, you know, risk for money loss
and being able to steal funds and all that kind of stuff.
So it's really, really interesting.
You mentioned XSS.
So I wanted to call this out because you have, uh, you have an XSS payload tattooed on your
arm, which is just crazy.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Hopefully it shows up in the camera if you're, if you're watching this on YouTube, but yes,
you do have a, you have an XSS payload tattooed on your arm.
Correct.
Can you tell me a little bit about that?
Uh, it's yeah.
At some point when you have enough tattoo tattoos, like your first tattoos, like you really think
about it for months and months and it has a special meaning to you, et cetera.
I just wanted to have a hacking tattoo.
Obviously hacking, uh, it means something to me nowadays.
I wanted to have a, uh, one that fits my arm.
So this is basically the shortest one that I could came up with.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
So, you know, I guess Joel and I always forget this is, you know, this is a podcast, so we've
got to appeal to the audio medium as well.
Um, so for those of you listening and not watching, it's a, it's the, uh, SVG onload, um, uh, payload, you know, one of the shortest ones you can get.
Um, and he's using, I like the decision to go with the slash between the G and the onload rather than the space.
Yeah.
I think that's great.
I think that, that allows the flow to go fully together.
Well, can you imagine if the spacing was wrong too?
Like if it's just like a little too wide, then it looks, it looks very weird.
I was very paranoid about it.
I rechecked the spelling like 10 times.
What did your tattoo artist think when you came in?
You were like, Hey, can I get this tattooed on my own?
Yeah, whatever you like.
I have no clue what this means or what you're getting, but I'll do it.
Yeah, dude.
It's funny.
Um, you know, I think I've mentioned this story on the pod before, but, uh, Tommy DeVos, Doggy G.
Uh, he's, he's the guy that kind of got me into bug bounty in the first place.
Cause we live in the same city.
And, uh, and he recently, he was in, we were in a group chat and he, um, was like saying, Oh yeah, I'm thinking about getting this tattoo.
And actually I think he posted on Twitter as well, but he, at one point he almost got the HTML source code of a, uh, of a, what is it?
The CVE details website tattooed on his arm because he meant to get the C code for a specific exploit.
But the guy went to the website and was like, Oh, I guess I'll just do the HTML code.
So he built it in and then he posted it and everyone's like, you're going to do HTML code on your arm.
And you know, with like, it does not even an XSS payload.
He's like, Oh shit, shit, shit.
Oh yeah.
And so I'm glad he did some sanity check there because.
I also got some comments when I posted it.
Like someone mentioned, uh, actually a kind of well-known hacker mentioned that this won't work if it's inserted in inner HTML.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I was not going for a polyglot.
Yeah.
No, it's funny because you said like, uh, you know, the first tattoo you always like really, really think about, and I've been thinking about getting a tattoo and I want it to be hacking related.
And I'm just like, I'm in that cycle where I'm like, uh, this would be kind of cool.
And I think about it for like, you know, a week or two.
I'm like, nah, it's not good enough.
And so you, you want that first one.
But my, my wife has a lot of tattoos and she was like, you know, she just goes and gets them like, you know, every couple months.
And yeah, she's just like, oh, I just, I'll get one here and one here and here.
Yeah.
So it's awesome.
That's cool.
Yeah, man.
I I've been thinking about it too.
And I actually kind of even got a design, you know, I'd like to do some, some circuitry and then, you know, integrate some HTTP request syntax and stuff like that.
And I'm kind of mapping out a web architecture, but the thing is, if you, if you go to Japan, then you can't get in the onsens, the spas, the, the, you know, the hot springs, the public baths.
And, uh, dude, I just love that.
I love that in Japan.
So like, right before we went on this trip to Japan, which we just got, we just, you know, flew from Japan straight to Portugal.
Uh, I was like, yeah, you know, I should, I'm really close to doing it.
I think I'll do it within the next couple months.
And then I go to Japan and I'm like sitting in the hot tub thinking like.
It's not worth it.
It's not worth it to me, man.
So I don't know, man, I guess it's a, I guess I, if Japan ever changes their policies, then I think I'll, I'll go down that route.
Um, all right, let's, let's, uh, let's bring it, bringing it back around.
Um, so you are, um, you know, top 10, uh, I guess in, in integrity.
Not, not more, not anymore.
Oh, not anymore.
I'm 11th.
Oh, he's 11th.
Okay.
Top, of course.
Done with the podcast.
Top 11 in integrity.
Um, you've been working on the platform, uh, you know, for quite a while.
Um, and, but you've also done, I think I saw in a tweet, you've done some hacker one stuff.
You've done some hack and proof stuff.
Um, talk to me about, I guess the experience of working.
There's like a fly here.
Uh, uh, there's, uh, about the experience of, of working on integrity and versus the experience
you've had on other platforms and kind of lay out the differences for me.
Uh, I'm actually a big fan of integrity because.
On other platforms, I often had the feeling that they would treat me like, uh, well, just like
clearing the backlog.
Mm-hmm.
Well, at integrity, there's really the triage team and the support team also always really
personal, especially, yeah, I think it would also help that I'm in the top because they know me
and that, that obviously helps, but in general, they're really, really open to feedback.
They help you along and they have some custom message for you.
Oh, nice to see you back on the program or whatever.
Not like just the, the thank you for your message number.
Yeah.
So that's, that's something I really like.
And I think, I think I started at the right time, uh, at integrity to, to be able to grow
along with the program, uh, with the platform to, to reach like, uh, the top 10.
Yeah.
And that helps.
So how did you find out about integrity?
Like what led you to even hack on integrity versus hacker one or bug crowd or any of the
other ones?
So there's actually a kind of funny story as well.
I was, uh, working at ball.com, which is like, uh, well, the tiny version of, uh, Amazon
within the Netherlands and Belgium.
Cool.
Um, and I was working on the security team there also managing the bug bounty program.
Got it.
And there was this dude also at the event, uh, who submitted some reports, uh, and, uh,
they were all valid and accepted and whatever.
And at some point he needed an internship and asked through hacker one to, uh, to get an internship,
uh, at our team, which, uh, he got.
Okay.
And he actually was already active on integrity and suggested, uh, I should have a look as well.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
So you were running a bug bounty program on hacker one.
Yes.
And then he was like, Hey, you should check out this platform integrity.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's very interesting.
Yep.
Wow.
Okay.
Very cool.
So then you just started hacking on integrity and were there, did you stick to one program
or like.
No, I, I, I often tried to like the top hackers that are really focused on one program.
I can't manage to do it.
I have like, I'd like to, my attention span is too short.
We all have ADHD.
Yeah.
I was, I was talking with, with, uh, with Renee in the car, you know, I was saying like so many
of the top hackers have like this, they're just absolutely brilliant.
And you know, we've had this conversation before, Joel, I even feel this way with you.
Like, like, I feel like my thing is not necessarily like the, you know, engine burning really hot,
you know, or the oven burning really hot, but the ability to like stay focused or stay committed
to something.
And it's amazing when, when, you know, you guys can actually direct that, that power at stuff.
I'm always like in awe.
So yeah.
But it, it does come with the side of like, you do have to jump around from.
Yeah.
For, well, for life hacking events, I do want to force myself to, to focus on the target.
So yeah.
And I do it from time to time, but, uh, yeah, I'm not, I'm not the type of guy that can totally
get into one program.
Yeah.
So do you do lots of events, lots of life hacking events?
Uh, I've done like five or six integrity events.
Okay.
Um, yeah, hacker one event.
All of them.
I think, right?
Yeah.
No, yeah.
They've had a bunch, but it was, I started during COVID, I guess some virtual ones.
Yeah.
So, uh, yeah, hacker one events is high on my bucket list, but I guess I'm not active
enough on hacker one yet to, uh, to.
We need like the status match that airline programs.
Yeah.
That's, that's, that's true.
I I've been thinking about that.
So we'll, we'll see, you know, how that goes, but I mean, obviously if you can hack one place
and you can hack in another place, but I will say there is something about life
hacking events.
Like you can see hackers that are phenomenal at, at, um, well, or even it goes both ways.
You can see people that are phenomenal at hacking in a normal context, but then when you put them
in a life hacking context, they, they can't, they can't do it.
Yeah.
Or the opposite as well is true.
You see some people that are like so motivated by the competition.
Right.
And they're like, oh, this is like amazing.
Like I can totally stay locked in, but then, you know, off, off platform, you know, or off,
uh, off the life hacking events, just on the platform, it's very hard for them to stay focused.
So it is, it is a little bit of a trade-off as well there.
And I'm curious.
So going back to the question about, um, you know, you're jumping around from program to program.
Like we've had people on the, on the podcast that are pretty extreme with this.
For example, Douglas Day, uh, our, our angel, uh, he says he'll give it like, you know, 30 minutes
to three hours or something like that.
Right.
Before he switches programs, if he doesn't find a bug.
And then we've also had people, I think maybe the most, uh, clear example of this would be Alex
Chapman or even me who are like, yeah, I'm going to sit down for a couple of weeks and try
this program until, you know, I either beat it or it beats me.
So where, where do you fall on that spectrum?
Um, depends on the mindset of the day of it, but typically I'm in the, in the days area.
Okay.
But I'm also, yeah, some days you have like, especially being a full-timer at the end of
the day, you think, I think, what have I done?
I've just skipped over like a hundred programs, checked out the scope, uh, asked for credentials
and then moved on.
Yeah.
So yeah.
That's really interesting.
I've actually been having a lot of conversations with hackers at, at this event who,
who participate in both integrity and hack one events and all that kind of stuff.
And, uh, the, I've, I've felt that over time, the more events that I do, it's actually very
difficult to like get to get to that deep dive state because oftentimes you'll be doing an
event and then there's another one coming up and you just have to start prepping for that.
And you have to like, you know, either focus on that one singular target, which is kind
of a deep dive, but it's not really the same when it, when it's forced in a sense, right.
Where like, you know, essentially you're being told, oh, you, you need to hack on this where
it's like, you know, I might have ideas about a program that I'm really interested in, but
I can't hack on it because I don't have, you know, the time or, you know, I need to be focusing
on this other program.
So, um, do you take notes?
How do you, how do you deal with that when you're going in between events and full-time hacking?
I take notes. I try to take notes, but yeah, it's like, uh, I've heard all the hackers say
the same thing. It's like the notes dot text with some random stuff in there. And, uh, yeah, I did,
when I became full-time, I, I did make it a habit to just put it in a Google drive auto sync
configuration. So I can look back at it. Typically I don't really use it a lot, but yeah.
It's, it's, it's crazy that that's, that we've actually seen that across so many top performing
hackers. I really would have expected that. And I guess, Joel, you're pretty much the closest thing
to this with how organized you are with your, you know, spreadsheets and stuff. But, um, we haven't
seen many, many hackers that do very structured notes, very detailed. Um, I think one hacker comes to
mind with this and it's mayonnaise on hacker one. I know that he takes extremely structured notes and even
does, um, data science on all of his like burp, uh, you know, files and like, you know, all that sort
of stuff. So that's pretty crazy. We might, we might should get him on the pod for like a counter,
a counter take on that. Um, but as, as a full, as a full-time hunter, you know, you mentioned you're
a full-time hunter. Um, I guess as a full-time hunter myself, I know that there's a lot of struggles
that go along with that. Um, and, and we've seen just looking at the history of that, um, how few,
you know, people actually make it the whole, uh, you know, even a year in, in full-time bug bounty
hunting. Um, so what, and you said you've been doing it for a year and a half. So tell me about
your experience and tell me about some of the struggles you've had with that.
For me, the most challenging part is working alone. Well, on the other hand,
it's also like a con. So that's the thing I'm, I actually struggle with the most. So
last winter in the Netherlands, I was still working from home, uh, and I'm in the attic
and it's raining outside and it's dark. Uh, yeah, I, there were many times where I thought to myself,
what am I, what am I doing with my life? Yeah. Yeah. So I tried to change that actually.
So since last May, I'm now in a, in a flex working, uh, co-working space office,
which is actually kind of nice, especially so I can have a commute to work and clear my mind when
going home, et cetera. So that's nice. Still working alone. Still, everyone is in their own
cubicle doing their own thing, but it's a, it's a nice change of pace, uh, during the day. Got it.
So that kind of like a, we work type thing that, uh, I don't know if you know that we have this in
the U S no, we have minus called spaces. I don't know. It's also kind of international,
but maybe in Europe, but yeah, it's something like that. Yeah. I have my own dedicated cubicle,
basically on the floor with all the cubicles. Okay. So it's just like a little one man office.
Yeah. Okay. Very, very, very cool. Is it like a monthly fee or how does that? Yes. Yeah. Okay.
That's really cool. I don't actually think I've heard of many hackers who do that. And I kind of
like, I know a lot of people, like the structure is like huge for, for being that, like, I'm not like
that at all. When COVID hit, I was like, oh, I have to stay inside. Okay, sweet. Like say less,
you know, like that, that's totally like how I am. But I know a lot of people were just like
dying to like, just like get outside or like get back into like the social interactions and that kind of stuff.
Yeah. I actually wanted to ask about that. Like I've struggled with that decision myself to go do
a, a, a, you know, we work or like a, you know, collaborative workspace. Um, and I think I don't
have kids, so I'm sure this might change when I have kids, but, um, like, do you mind if I ask how
much that costs every month? Do you know? Mine is like, uh, in dollars? No, no, no. It's like 400 euros or something. 400 euros. Okay. So that's, that's,
yeah. Like I would, I would definitely struggle with that decision, even though 400 euros is not,
you know, too much to be paying for that sort of thing. I did as well actually. And, uh, because I
had to pay like, I, I, you commit to like a year or something. Oh, really? Wow. But, uh, it was actually
around the time when I make the 50k. So I just said to myself, well, let's do this times 12, see what the
total amount is. And then I'll just, I took that from the, from the bounty, put it in a separate
accounting savings account. And then I was like, done. I keep it, get rid out of it out of my head.
And, uh, this is it. That's fun. Yeah. I was watching a video today. It was, uh, it was very,
it was like a plumber or something in New York City, but, but he was basically saying like,
just to like walk out the door and get in his car and like, go, go do a job is at minimum like a
thousand dollars a day just in, you know, parking and insurance and all that kind of stuff. And so like,
if you sort of extrapolate it out, like, I think that's almost a good way to think about it where
it's like, okay, if it's say 400 euros a month or whatever, it's a hundred euros a week. That's like,
you know, your operating cost basically. It's like, okay, I need to make a hundred euros this week.
And that's it. If I don't make a hundred euros this week, I make 200 euros next week. Right. And so like,
you, if you can frame it that way, I think that that kind of helps because setting those,
those goals is really good. One way I like to think about it is, you know, I sort of frame it as like
a yearly salary. Like say I want, you know, X dollars per year, divide that
by 12 or divided by 52 weeks or whatever. Okay. I need to make this much per week. I need to make
this much per month. And that's sort of like, you know, if I get a bounty, that's that much or more,
I'm like, sweet. I'm, you know, I don't have, like, if I make more, that's great. But if I don't,
like, I know that I'm going to hit, you know, this much per year. And that's like, it's a lot easier
for me to have that sort of system in my mind where, um, it's more like split out and it's almost like a
salary type thing instead of the grind. And I think a lot of people, when they think about doing full-time
bugbinding, they're like, oh, well, where's, where's that next bounty coming from? Where's that
next paycheck? Like there's no paycheck. Right. And so I think if you, if you have it like that,
where it's like, you know, you have monthly things that you know, you have to pay for and all that
kind of stuff, it's nice to kind of structure it. Yeah. I do it exactly like this. So before I started,
I made sure I had a financial buffer to be able to fail basically. So at the time, the buffer was like
six months or something. And now the buffer is like a year or something. But I also just,
I give myself a salary, a fixed salary, and then I'll just keep filling the buffer.
And it doesn't matter if it overflows or if it gets a bit less, but as long as it's a solid amount of
money in there, then, uh, I'm content. That's really interesting. I, I actually have a different
approach to this. Um, I guess I do still have all the money come into my company and then I pay myself
a normal amount out of that account. But I also found it a little, um, stressful for me if I say,
okay, I want to earn X thousand a year and then divide that by 12. And then, you know, this is what
I need to make every month because of the volatility of Pug Bounty. Right? And so like, for example,
if I, you know, if I've got six bugs, 10 bugs, 15 bugs in the, in the pipeline, but, and it switches
over to October or whatever, and I'm like, ah, you know, I didn't make as much as I needed in September,
then it kind of stresses me out a little bit. So I try to look, look at it more from like a, a holistic
perspective of like, I have enough money in my buffer, you know, to make it through, you know,
the end of this year for sure. And then I look back on the year and I say, okay, I made X amount
that past year. Um, you know, I'll try to shoot for, cause it is helpful to have goals. You know,
I'll try to shoot for roughly, you know, X plus one X plus two, you know, 1.5 times X or 1.2 times X,
you know, for the, for the next year. Um, but breaking it down into individual months for me is just like,
Oh, cause yeah. Cause it just, it, it, it really, you know, if I don't hit a goal, I'm like, come on.
Yeah. Yeah. I, I don't look at it from a monthly perspective. Like I look back a year typically to
see how I'm doing, but yeah, I'll, I'll keep the monthly payments the same. So I don't have to worry
about what's coming in. Yeah. So, I mean, on the topic of money, you, I think you posted on Twitter
that you're, you know, looking for a job or doing consulting or stuff. So was that monetarily driven?
Did you just want to kind of reduce that stress or what sort of led you towards that?
Yeah. This is actually, uh, related to what we're talking about. So, uh, uh, the, the thing I struggle
with is like working alone, like all your colleagues are also your competitors, uh, and are like, uh, on the
other side of the world. So I can, uh, I can't easily ask them a question. Uh, so that's the,
like the main reason why I was looking into getting a job again. Uh, but I also posted it,
like, just see what pops up, right? I'm not at a stage where I'm desperate to have a job or to
desperate to change something overnight because I can't take it anymore. Just like I said, it,
it's, it's a bit, I'm a bit conflicted with the working alone because it's also, I also really like
it. I also really like not having to do with meetings that I don't care about, not having to
report to a manager that has an opinion on my performance. So that's, that's the plus side of
bug bounty, obviously.
Dude, I, the meeting thing is, it's so foreign to me, man. Like I, I was talking to a friend in Japan
the other day who's like, yeah, there's this guy in my organization that like will ping me. This isn't
even his superior. This is his, um, you know, same level dude. And he'll be like, Hey, um, we're gonna have
a meeting in 10 minutes and it's going to be an hour long meeting. And, and, and he just drops it
on him like that. And I'm like, dude, you gotta, you gotta say no to that. Like you gotta, like,
there's no way I could live my life, you know, with like, but on the other hand also, you know,
if I've got a meeting on my calendar, it's like, Oh, okay, I've got a four hour block here. What can I
accomplish in a four hour block? You know? And, and the four hour, and the reason why, you know, that
affects me is because it does take so much focus to do bug bounty. Like I find it very hard
to jump in and out of a flow state, you know, of your focus state and bug bounty.
So I definitely, I definitely understand that there.
Yep. Yeah. So speak, speaking of flow state, what is like, what's your,
oh, I just went through puberty again. Wow. Uh, so what, sorry.
So what, what is your, uh, what is your hacking like flow actually look like? What do you, you know,
when you approach a target, what's, what is, what is your mindset? How do you look at the target?
What are the first things you do? Um, what are the things you look for?
I think I'm always really interested if people have a good answer to this because I, I don't
really have a good answer. It's so broad, right? The question.
Well, I tip, I, I like, yeah, we talked about XSS. I've, I've built some browser plugin tooling to
help me find stuff. I also posted about, about it on Twitter a few times. So typically my flow is just
clicking buttons in a website and basically having burp open, uh, checking the output of some of
these plugins that I've built. And that's basically how I get into the application.
A lot of top hackers have that answer. And, and that, the question that we asked, we, we pose,
you know, to see if anybody has a quick answer to get, have structure, because if they do, that's
really cool. But so many of the top hackers say exactly what you said, and that's great for the top
hackers. Right. But I'm also, as I've worked with mentees and people that are trying to get that
sense, I wonder how you came to that. So, so do you, do you, let's think back, you know, uh, you know,
you've, you've been studying music forever and now you're, you know, you're going into, into bug bounty
related stuff. You know, I guess maybe you had a job at, at bowl and security beforehand, but, um,
how did you, when you first approached to target, was it, was it similar or did you use a checklist or how
did, how did you, how did you know what to look for? It's a hard question. I'm sorry. I, I know it's tricky.
Yeah. I guess it's something that you learn over time. Yeah. Uh, what really helped me and still
helps me is sometimes I, uh, like I said, I've built some browser extensions that do stuff basically.
Yeah. And to, to read, uh, refine the output a bit, to look into, uh, alerts popping up. I think that
really helps me to get a sense of what's happening. But it's an interesting question. Actually, I, I,
I guess I have that sense for XSS and there are some other hackers also at the event. I once had
a discussion about, uh, with Kuro Matai, he was also at the event. He was really, really good in SQL injection.
And I was like, dude, SQL injection does that even exist still? Exactly. Same. Yeah. And he's like
testing with a single quote somewhere and gets one byte difference in the responses. Like, yes,
that's an SQL injection. No way. What a beast. Yeah. I got to, I got to meet them. There's so
many people here that I don't actually have often because we'll, we'll mention this as well. The
event is, uh, is a sort of, it's possible to self sponsor yourself to come to this event. You know,
it's possible to pay the amount for the ticket and the hotel and come over here. So there's so
many faces here that I haven't actually seen at the live hacking events before, but I see on Twitter
all the time. Um, so I've really, there's been so many people I want to meet, but it's interesting that
XSS stood out to you specifically from the beginning and that you actually went through the,
the process of creating tooling specifically for it. Is there a reason why XSS is like your shit?
Or did you, did you like, are you, were you a JS developer before or? No, not at all. I'm also a
terrible developer in any, in any, but, uh, what I like about this actually, we touched upon it a bit.
Like I like code review, but also at the same time clicking buttons. And I guess that's where
yeah, that's, that's where JavaScript comes in. Right. So I have some solid issues on like open
source stuff where I could also do the same basically, but then on the server side. Yeah.
So that's nice. But yeah, typically, yeah, that's what I like about XSS also because
JavaScript is so it's, it's so crazy. You can do like anything. You can have like a million ways to the
same goal. Yeah. I like about the, I like that about it. That's really interesting. So can you
tell me a little bit, I don't, I don't, don't know if you're comfortable with sharing so many of your
secrets or whatever, but what are some of these extensions or browser plugins or whatever that
you've, that you've written to help yourself? So I've one, I've one that is actually really basic,
but it just, uh, monitors every URL, the browser fetches and if it has any query parameters and then it
will inject just like a, a harmless payload into every query parameter and see if it's reflected.
Okay. So I like the reflector plugin from burp, but what I like about keeping it in the browser is that
in burp, you constantly have to switch focus. You have to see if there is this valid something.
And now I've just built it. Like it will literally pop an alert saying XSS here while I'm clicking
buttons. So sometimes when I approach a new target and I'm clicking buttons, I found my first few XSS
is just by browsing the application. Got it. And so does it basically just like put the query parameter
in your payload so that you know which, where it's coming from or how do you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's alerts like the, the URL with my injection. Nice. Yeah. So that's really nice.
Yeah. And so, and another one I did this, like an extension on Franz Rosen's, uh, post message tracker.
Dude, I love that. Yeah.
So I recently, I really liked the extension. What I dislike about it is that you, for every page you
visit, you have to click it open to see if something pops out to you. So I made like a really small
adaptation that will just look for a low hanging fruit, like XSS syncs, like eval or whatever.
And if it's in there already, then it will pop up an alert and just, uh, yeah, prompt me to check it out.
And yeah, especially I've been a bit of obsessed with post messages.
Dude, post message stuff is so fascinating. I have been too. And it's like, I feel like there's a lot
of untapped potential there, especially as these apps sort of move towards a framework, you know,
every, every app that you, you, you work with now is using like, you know, react or angular view,
whatever these single page apps, you know, it's kind of hard to get anything besides Dom XSS. So
being able to do post message stuff is really, that, that really helps a lot and it expands the
access has scope quite a bit. Yeah. There's so much still so much low hanging fruit. I was really
surprised about it. And it also seems like every, like a lot of websites have this support chat button
thing. It seems like all these providers are vulnerable somehow. Yeah. Well, yeah, because I
think it's really interesting that we've seen browsers, increased security, like cross window,
cross tab, all that kind of stuff. But in order, in order to do that and keep things functional and make
it so that you can have like a nice user experience where, you know, PayPal checkout,
for example, you click the button, it pops up a window or well, it has to communicate somehow.
Right. And same thing with these chat support buttons or the wallets or all this stuff that
we've been talking about, these things have to be able to communicate somehow. And often this ends
up being post message. And so it's, it's like a very widely used piece of technology, but I think it's
quite underexplored. Yeah. And insecure by default. Oh yeah, absolutely. Right. Like there's no default
checks. It's not checking for origin. All that stuff is up to the developer. And so,
so many developers are just like, it's not even on their radar, right? It's not even something that
they know they should be looking for or even concerned about, because I don't, I don't think
it's very intuitive that you would expect, oh, you know, some random website might I frame my website
and then start talking with it. Right. Like, it's not really an attack scenario that you're,
you're going to think about. And so I think it's super, super underexplored and there's a lot of
research to happen there. Yeah. Thanks for, thanks for looking right at me when you say there's a lot of,
a lot of research to happen there. Joel knows about, and I'll share this with you off air,
Renee, but there's, there's a piece of post message related research that I've been working on. And then
I finally got to a place where it's like, oh, this is going to break some shit. So that'll be coming soon.
I'm not ready to talk about that one super, super much yet, but the, the post message space is,
is truly fascinating. And there's a lot of volumes there. And like you highlighted, Joel,
if you understand the concepts behind, you know, browser security, you know, your, your same origin
policy and you see, Hey, this, these pages somehow are communicating between the two of them. That
should ask you, you should ask why, why is that happening? How is that happening?
No. Um, and oftentimes the answer is, is post message. So definitely a cool, a text base there.
Do you have, before we move on, I guess, do you have any, so obviously you've made a modification to
the post message tracker by Franz Rosen. Um, and that's, that's a great piece of software for people
to install. Um, to even just get introspection into how post messages are, are working on the page.
Definitely. Do you have any other, uh, tips or tricks you've run across in the post message arena
that you'd like to pass off or, or is it mostly just understanding the logic of each individual page?
I think that's the, that's the thing. Uh, also, yeah, like you said, the origin check is like the
key factor almost in the, in this stuff. And that's what we're talking about. Like getting a sense for
stuff. Like now the past weeks I've been hyper focused on post message. And now if I get the,
the popup, I see instance, do you see like T dot origin or that? Okay. Yeah. Not this one.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's awesome. I mean, there's so many things that just, I think come intuitively
to us that now that we've been doing hacking for so long that you just, you see post message,
you're like, Oh, okay. Like I know how this works or I know how this is probably going to work.
Um, and it's, it's fun. We were, we were hacking with friends yesterday during the event and well,
during the pre event, I guess. And, uh, he guessed a, he guessed we were doing like a path,
uh, what a secondary context, uh, path traversal and path substitution.
And he gets, he realized, okay, it's three paths up. And he guessed what the legitimate,
like API path that was being used in the backend was just based on like, Oh yeah,
I think this is probably how this works. And he just was like trying different stuff and we
couldn't actually brute force it because there was a rate limit. And so he was just like manually
testing some stuff. And five minutes later, he was like, Oh, I got it. Like, wait, what?
It's like this totally internal endpoint. It's crazy, crazy.
Yeah, dude, that blew my mind. And it, and it really shows like, you know, people have different
intuitions at different spots and it's all about, you know, when you're growing as a hacker,
it's all about sort of fostering those intuitions. Um, and I will, but going back to what we were
talking about with the post messages origin thing, I will say, I, I normally I do the same thing,
right? Where I see like, you know, whatever t dot origin or whatever. All right, whatever.
Like I'm, I'm done with that. Just throw it away. But lately I've been, I've kind of looked at a
little bit closer at some of this stuff and I've seen so many developers get regular expressions
wrong in that context. Um, if, if you see an origin being compared to a regular expression,
and they're not escaping the dots, there's going to be problems there. And I just, it's that same,
you know, age old story of like, thank God for whoever came up with dots to be, to be any character
in regular expressions. Like it's the most legendary thing ever. And I'm so grateful for it. Um, so
definitely be on the lookout for that one when you're checking out post message stuff. Um, okay. So I
wanted to actually ask you about two tweets that I had, you know, when I, when I stalked you on Twitter
before we, you know, we do the interview. Um, you had, so one you've done recently was a sort of an
XSS scenario where you're like, where you had the following conditions recently encountered.
I'm just going to read the tweet recently encountered a challenging stored XSS case,
no dots, no parentheses, no plus, no single quote, no space. And wait, was that no space character?
Yeah, no space character. Okay. I was going to say, no space.
Cause the next line says max 35 characters, which is no space. Um, and then unlimited amount of
payloads that can be stored. Every payload is reflected twice.
Yeah. Which is so funny because as you were reading through those, I'm going through my mental
checklist. I'm like, Oh, I know a bypass for that. I know a bypass for that. Ooh, that cancels my,
but Oh, Oh, Oh, I'm running out of bypasses.
Yeah.
Very intense, you know, XSS scenario. Um, and you, you know, you represented most of it here in the tweet,
but, uh, talk to me a little bit about your, your testing procedure for that. And can you tell me
like how long it took you to actually get to the solution you put in between? Quite a while actually.
Yeah. So we were having a, we have a discord server with quite some hackers. And once a year,
we, we tend to meet up in a big villa in the Netherlands and people fly in from all of it. Like
some last year, people from America flew in and said, it was really nice. And this year we got,
yes, we hacked to arrange us some fresh targets to hack. Awesome.
But this was a really nice program. Uh, and I was basically, well, in my same flow again,
just pasting stuff in there and, uh, clicking buttons. Yeah. Uh, Harmony was also in this event.
He reached out to me saying, uh, dude, you're escaping HTML here. So maybe you have an XSS.
And then we looked into it. It was like, it was like, uh, meant, a field meant for, uh, an identifier.
So it would do stuff like, uh, uh, replace spaces with underscores and stuff like that. So, and it,
like, if you added, uh, uh, the plus symbol, it would just write out plus in letters and stuff like
that. So it was really challenging setup. Uh, but we could like use enough characters to, uh, a new,
we could put in enough payloads to like, yeah, get a full payload in the end. Uh, so yeah, we had quite some
challenging stuff to work around all these things. That's awesome. I love that, that little, uh,
you know, hacker house type thing. We've done that a couple of times, uh, throughout the years at
different events. Oftentimes we'll do it after the event. Uh, we did that in Japan. We went to Hakuna
and, um, that's where we recorded with Lupin and, uh, you know, just, it's, it's awesome to have that
kind of, it's a lot more relaxing than the actual, like, right in the heat of the live events and to
just be able to kind of hang out and still have those kind of hacker discussions and stuff. You have,
um, what is it? A hacker hideout? I think it's called. Is that, is that what that is?
No, no. Okay. Well, I would wish, I would wish it was that now it's actually kind of
hacker hideout also originates from, uh, my quest to get an office space actually,
because I was looking for an office space and I was thinking like how awesome would it be if you
have like an office for bug bounty hunts, like a flex working space where people could just drop in,
hire an office for a day or something. And now, and then I was looking into that because
yeah, I needed my own office space. So maybe I can create like something to do that, uh, with others.
And then I found out that like the full-time bug bounty community in the Netherlands is like
five people or something. Oh yeah.
All over the world, you know, it's, it's, it's kind of hit or miss. So I, I, I'd be really,
but, but I think actually there are a decent amount of people that are in offensive security,
you know, and so, and, and those, those positions do tend to be remote, you know?
And so there, you know, maybe there's some possibilities there.
The idea got converted. I started it together with the host also at the event here to first,
just try to build a small community. Uh, we didn't want to open up a discord and allow everyone in,
but just like, uh, uh, in crowd of people, uh, and maybe, well, maybe do like, just do like fun stuff,
like the Villa part. We also do like meetups or whatever. So, uh, in this event, we, uh, we,
well, we started out with creating our own, uh, our own hacking team basically. So yeah.
Yeah. That's great, man. Yeah. I, I hope that that takes off because anytime you can get a bunch
of hackers in a space together, it really does, you know, crazy stuff happens.
Yeah, definitely.
All the time.
Well, I mean, that's like why we started the podcast too, is we wanted to be able to sort of extend
these conversations that are able to be had by hackers behind closed doors with the rest of
the community so that they can learn from it because there's so much value. Like every time
I come to one of these events and I'm talking with people, even if it's just like 20, 30 minutes,
it's there's so much like hackers have a level of understanding of what each other are doing to
so much of a degree that you can just immediately, like, even if like, we've never met, this is the
first time we met, we can just have this conversation and we know exactly like what, where the other
one's coming from because we've like been through that same kind of hacking experience.
And it's so awesome to be able to have those same connections with so many hackers.
Yeah, definitely.
And it's so like the knowledge sharing is just incredible. Like, I don't even know how to express
like how valuable the knowledge sharing is between hackers at these events. And so, you know, I think
it's really important to create a space that fosters that kind of, you know, that energy and that kind
of, you know, community where you can have an open space where you can talk with hackers and you
can collaborate and you can share ideas and bounce stuff off of each other.
Yeah, that works great. And also, also within our team now, I think I'm, I could say without being
like, uh, proud without flexing, I'm, I'm the most experienced bug bounty hunter in my team,
but, uh, the most brilliant ideas came from my teammates.
Isn't that crazy? Isn't it crazy how that always works? Like, it seems like when, when you work with
some of the newer people, like as you're re-explaining stuff, you're like, oh wait, why do I think that way?
You know? And so it, and not even when you're explaining, but just when a fresh set of eyes
is on the scenario, that's really helpful. Definitely. I really like that. Also, also
with the XSS payload that we just discussed, the very limited one, I, I deliberately post those on
Twitter just to get feedback. And like Johan Carlson is also at the event. So I was like in the first
tweet, I'll be, you could just URL escape, uh, URL encode the dots and then you're done. Like,
bookmarking. Hmm. Thank you. Thank you for that. This would save me like five hours of my life.
Love that for me. Thank you. Thank you. No, that's, that's great, man. It is great when
we have the community together. Yeah. Well, and it's, it's really funny because me and you, me and
Justin, we hack, we hack a lot together and we do a lot of pair hacking. Oftentimes it's not even that
we're like both at our laptops, but I'll just be like sitting next to him. We'll just be sort of
observing and I'll be like, Hey, you know, maybe you could try this or you could try that and he'll do the same
thing. And I think it's, it's so valuable because when you have been working on a bug for
hours or days or whatever, you, you make a lot of assumptions, right? Where you're like, Oh, I,
I, you know, this is probably not happening or, you know, I'm like 99% sure that this is the case.
Or you just, you know, you don't even think about it because you're very focused on like a goal.
Yeah. And then when somebody new comes in, they'll start asking, they're not dumb questions, but they're,
you know, they're sort of like, you know, they don't have the same kind of background context that you
do because they haven't been looking at that bug for so long. And oftentimes those are the most valuable
questions where they'll be like, well, have you just tried this? And you're like, Oh, why,
why haven't I tried that? I probably should try that.
That's the case here as well. You're like committed to the, the, the path you're taking. Like you have
to, the payload is halfway there. So you're not committed or you're not prepared to give up on it.
Don't throw it like, so you make it work somehow. Yeah. The, the only, so we're, we're coming to a wrap
here. And, uh, the only other thing that I really wanted to make sure we hit on this podcast was
sort of talking about the integrity event that we're at right now. We talked a little bit about
integrity as a platform, but, um, I guess just some thoughts from, for the community, from this event,
for me is that, uh, one of the coolest things is that, you know, people can pay their way, their own way,
like we talked about. And I think there's, there's some pluses to that and there's some downsides to
that, right? The plus is that you get to see a lot of new faces. You get to see, you know, the people
that are successful in the industry and that contribute on Twitter and stuff like that, but
haven't necessarily been at the life hacking event scene. Um, and that's really great. The downside of
that though, is that there are so many hackers and especially if you have a scope that's a little bit
more constrained, which would normally be great for a normal size life hacking event. I think when you
open it up to so many people, the dupes start getting a little overwhelming. So that's one
thought for me. It's challenging. Yeah. I think I heard yesterday that there was a bug that got,
uh, it was like $1,100 and everybody got $11, which means I got split a hundred times.
I think the lowest boundary I've seen is like $4.63. Yeah. And, and I think some of those ones,
you know, they're, they're fixing some stuff. Uh, I, I had a conversation with them this morning,
but, um, uh, one of the other things they did at this event was that they had a channel in Slack for
uh, knowledge sharing and that knowledge sharing was incentivized by, by bonuses. Yes. And man,
did that save our butts this event. Um, so really like to see that. Um, and I've got a couple other
things as well, but did you, did you have any thoughts you wanted to share about this event?
Yeah. I thought, uh, indeed the, the sponsored non-sponsored thing was really interesting for
me personally. I wouldn't have attended if it was self-sponsored, I guess, because yeah,
my reasoning was this is a job for me and to pay to be able to perform my job was a bridge too far for
me basically. So, so I wasn't in the first batch of invites and then the self sign up, uh, period started
and I was like, well, let's just pray. I get the invite in the second batch and then I got invited
luckily. So that's nice. That's awesome. Yeah. I'm actually really surprised you weren't in the first
batch of invites because I mean, you're so high on the integrity platform that I mean, it's very hit
or miss. I was at one of the very first ones. I don't even know if I can say the target. It was
the banking app is what I'll say. Uh, yeah. And, uh, that was, that was really interesting, but,
um, I, you know, it was kind of the first time they'd ever done anything like that. It was very,
you know, small and, and, and this is such a different type of vibe to that where it's,
you know, it's very big. It's very, you know, there's so many people and I, I actually,
I do like the self-sponsored thing. I'm actually self-sponsored for this one. Um, you know, part of
it is just half vacation, half, you know, getting to see hacker friends. I've never been to Portugal,
so it's fun. And I had a bunch of miles that were just sitting around doing nothing. So yeah,
I think if you can make it work, you can make it work, but it's nice to offer that opportunity for,
you know, people really, really want to be here. Absolutely. You can pay to win if it,
well, yeah, pay to arrive, you know, maybe not win, but, but yeah, you can definitely pay to get
here and, uh, you can sort of, you know, show that you have the capabilities. I think it can be really,
really difficult for new hackers to break into the live hacking space because there's so much
competition here and the people who are hacking at these events all the time are just insanely
talented. Um, and so, you know, getting a spot can be very, very difficult unless you're doing full-time
hacking or unless you find a bunch of crazy bugs in a short period of time. Right. So.
Yeah, absolutely, man. There's that's definitely been a big piece. So it's cool to see it go sort
of both ways there, you know, getting to see everyone's, you know, face and that sort of thing,
but also seeing the, the downside of like, oh, no, I guess maybe sometimes 40, have 40 people live
hacking events is not, is not so bad. No, definitely. Yeah. Yeah. So, so one other thing that I saw as
well, and we'll, we'll come back to you as well, see if you got anything else to share. But one of the
things that I saw was that they have, uh, or at least they're supposed to later today have a little
sort of help desk of sorts for going and sort of debating your bugs.
Oh, really?
So, so normally, you know, you, you've got to go and you've got to be like, for any of you that,
for anyone that's been to a live hacking event, you know how this works, but you know, it's like,
knock, knock, knock, bang on the door. Like, Hey, I need to talk to someone about that, you know, like,
and then you get to have a conversation. Right. And then, you know, you resolve it. But I thought it was really,
really cool that, um, you know, they sent out a message saying, Hey, there should be a dedicated
time later today to discuss some, some changes to your, you know, severity, or maybe is it a dupe?
Is it not a dupe? Um, so I think that could be really cool if integrated long-term into the,
into the bug bounty life hacking event scene.
Yeah. That's nice. Yeah. Yeah. This morning was also, I was fuming about some decisions.
And so it's good that we do this now and not me shouting at the Intel people or something.
Yeah. I mean, I, I think we've talked about this before, but that is one of the most
powerful things about a live hacking event is that you're onsite with the customer.
And it's really, really hard to have that type of that same level of communication with that's
like face to face over just, you know, posting a comment on your report or whatever, because it may
not be, you know, you never know which team member is going to read that, or if it's triage team or
whatever, like instead of you can just walk up and have a human discussion with somebody and you can
actually just get to the bottom of it. And it's happened with myself, you, but I mean, both of us
together, even on bugs, multiple, multiple times at events where we've gone and we've talked to the
customer and we've been like, you know, I think there's a misunderstanding in this bug here.
Let me show you and look, you know, let's, let me see what you, cause here's what I see.
I don't know if you're seeing the same thing. Like, let me make sure that we're on the same page here.
And maybe if I'm misunderstanding something, you can explain that to me. And you know, that,
that level of interaction is super, super helpful to just like get to the bottom of a bug without
getting mad and stuff. I, you know, we, I won't, I won't disclose anything, but one of our buddies,
uh, he, uh, he got a little, he got a little trouble. He was a little, you know, he was a little
too raw with, with the customer at one point. So, you know, I think it's important that, uh, you know,
it's good to be honest, but not, not, not a hundred percent all the time. So that's, that's the nice
thing about being able to just talk with the customers. They can sort of read your facial expression
and all that. Yeah. Well, you, you, you know, the hackers, they they've had, you know, when you're online,
there's always that whole online thing, right? Like you can, you can like,
you can keyboard warrior it, you know, if you want to, but I think people have had more experience
in their lifetime of like, Oh, well maybe I shouldn't, you know, be as irate if I'm meeting
with someone in person and seeing, Hey, they're just a person on the other side of the computer as well,
trying to do their best, you know? And, and I think integrity and, and the, the client,
I guess we'll say for this event has done a good job. Yeah. It's public.
Okay. Yeah. Intel, they, they do a great job.
Yeah, they do definitely.
And particularly shout out to, uh, you know, Chris flying toasters.
Yeah, definitely.
You know, he, he always throws great events. So, uh, I, I appreciate that.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. I, um, I, I was thinking, uh, just the other day, how, uh,
having worked in like a professional job now has changed my communication style so much.
Yeah.
Like when I was younger, before I had, you know, worked a corporate job, I would be very raw.
I would just, you know, if it came into my mind, I'd just frigging say it, you know? And, uh, now,
like, I, you know, once you work at a company, you kind of master the art of, uh,
writing passive aggressive emails and, you know, you, you, you get good at like writing something
and like, I'm not happy about this. Thank you very much. Have a nice day. You know? And, uh,
I think that's really, it's that kind of communication skill is so useful.
Yeah. And, uh, you know, I see it a lot with people who've, you know, worked like you've worked at
an app sec and at big companies and stuff. And so I think that experience is just really, really valuable.
Yeah. I think so too. Yeah. Because especially if you work, like if you're handling incoming bug
bounty reports, you left to like sell someone else's reports within your organization. Like,
this is really critical. You should pick it up. You should drop all the features you're building
and pick this up. So that, I guess that's a useful skill also when being a bug bounty hunter yourself.
Yeah. It's, it's so interesting to me when I hear people in apps that talk about like SLAs with their own
company, like, you know, they're, they're saying like, okay, I can, you know, I have this agreement
that I've, you know, negotiated with the, you know, programming division. Like they have to address
our issues within a month. And I'm like, this is the same company. Like, like, why is this so
complicated? But it, you know, it is in the end. And, and I've never even thought about that actually,
you know, that, that the people on, on your side of, when you're on the receiving side of report,
you then have to represent that report to your team, to your developers.
So yeah, thanks for all the hard work guys.
You're welcome.
Us, us, you know, bug hunters, I do appreciate it, whether we say it or not.
You know, Rene, any other, any other thoughts on the live hacking event? I've got, I think maybe
one or two I can, I can throw out there, but.
Not really?
Yeah.
You go ahead.
It's been, it's been a good time, you know, I, I think the, for me, it's really nice to meet
the Integrity team because it was my first live hacking event. Obviously I've spent with
Integrity. I've spent time with Inti before, which is great. He's always a pleasure to see.
Yeah.
But particularly like, Integrity, Travis, and, and some of the other guys have just been
really pleasant to be around. And it's been a really nice experience. And I also really like
the structure of that they've done here. So with, and I guess there's trade-offs to both,
but with the HackerOne live hacking events, how it goes is that, you know, you fly in, you, you know,
do your, you know, opening cocktail hour or whatever, that either that same day or the next
day, if you're international, and then you, you do a hacking day and then you do a community day.
And that community day is just kind of running around with friends and, and hanging out and
stuff like that. And the hacking day is like pretty much all focused on the event and that sort of thing.
Yes.
And it, that's nice in that sense, because you, you're done with the hacking at the community
day point and you don't feel tempted to hack. So I've always been really a fan of that structure.
But this event is also really nice too, where they have multiple hacking days and then community
stuff in the, in the evenings. Because that one, it gives you more time to collab with your, with your
friends, right? You get to work on the event a little bit more, but also it forces you to put the
bugs down a little bit and walk away. I have a really hard time with that personally. So I've
enjoyed the variety in the structure and, and like I said, the team has been very accommodating. So
overall, it's been, it's been a pretty cool event. The bounties are still, are still rolling in. So
we'll see how the final, the final payout...
Justin is checking his phone right now to see if he got a bounty.
No bounty. No, but that's, that's no fault, but my own perhaps. And so we'll see how the final
payouts roll through. But overall, yeah, pretty, pretty solid event. So happy to, happy to have been
here. Yeah. So I guess we'll, we'll close off there. Rene, thanks for coming on the pod, man.
Thanks for having me.
You said, you know, I'll, I'll pull up the, the socials right now on, on, on Twitter. Of course,
we have it as Rennie Pak and that's the same thing for Integrity. And then on LinkedIn, I'm going to let
you say the name, because I'm going to mispronounce it. Ignore me on LinkedIn. Okay. Ignore me on
LinkedIn. Only go follow on Twitter and on... Yeah. Visit the hackerhideout.xyz. Yes.
Hackerhideout.xyz. That's another great thing to check out. Where is that specifically? Like,
are you guys doing that all within, within the Netherlands or do you have a specific city?
We don't have a concrete plan on that yet, but we're trying to, we're really trying to take it step by
step to, well, like guarantee the quality of the community. What's the target demographic though?
Netherlands residents or? Not specifically. Okay. Gotcha. So this could be bigger than just the
Netherlands if you have a group of hackers. So the dream is still to have an office somewhere or
perhaps all around the world, but that's like, that's dream, dream. Very cool, man. Well,
I'm looking forward to see you get it. Cool. Thanks guys. All right. Thanks, Ben. Thanks.